♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS YOU
OUGHT TO KNOW ABOUT
KAMALA HARRIS, AND WE AIM TO
TELL YOU, BUT THE FIRST THING TO
KNOW ABOUT HARRIS ISN’T JUST A
FEW MONTHS SHE CAN RUN YOUR
COUNTRY.
IF JOE BYNES WINS, SHE WILL
EFFECTIVELY BECOME THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT, DEMOCRATIC
DONORS UNDERSTAND IT BEST OF ALL
ALL.
AMERICA’S BIG BANKS HAVE LONG
CONTROLLED WITH JOE BIDEN.
FOR YEARS IN THE SENATE, FOR
DECADES HE FAITHFULLY DID THEIR
BIDDING AND IN RETURN THEY SENT
HIM MONEY.
THEY STILL DO.
IN FACT FAR MORE MONEY THAN THEY
SEND TO THE INCUMBENT PRESIDENT.
THE BANKS WERE NERVOUS FOR A
MOMENT ABOUT THE PROSPECT THAT
BIDEN MIGHT PICK STACY ABRAMS,
SO THEY WERE THRILLED WHEN HE
CHOSE HARRIS INSTEAD.
ON TWITTER THEY CHEERED THE
NEWS.
THE CONSULTING GROUPS SENT THEM
BULLETINS TELLING ITS CLIENTS TO
CALM DOWN AND REST EASY.
THE DEMOCRATIC TICKET IS UNDER
CONTROL.
OUR CONTROL.
LAST NIGHT, IN FACT, THE DNC
HOSTED A FUND-RAISER.
SO ALL IS WELL ON WALL STREET.
BUT HOW ABOUT THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY?
ACTUAL VOTERS HAVE NEVER SHOWN A
LOT OF ENTHUSIASM FOR
KAMALA HARRIS.
IN FACT HARRIS WAS SO REMARKABLY
UNPOPULAR IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARIES THAT DESPITE NONSTOP
MEDIA CHEERLEADING SHE WAS
FORCED TO DROP OUT BEFORE THE
FIRST VOTES WERE EVEN CAST,
BEFORE CHRISTMAS.
BIDEN’S HANDLERS KNOW THIS,
OBVIOUSLY.
THEY WERE THERE, THEY WATCHED
IT, BUT THEY DON’T CARE.
THEY ARE BETTING THAT YOU HATE
DONALD TRUMP SO MUCH THAT YOU
WILL MAKE KAMALA HARRIS
PRESIDENT ANYWAY.
LIKE THEIR FRIENDS AT GOOGLE,
THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN UNDERSTANDS
IT HAS A MONOPOLY AND THEY PLAN
TO EXPLOIT IT.
THIS IS NOT THE DEMOCRACY WE
WERE PROMISED.
IN FACT, IT’S NOT A DEMOCRACY AT
ALL.
IT’S OLIGARCHY AND IT HAS
CONSEQUENCES FOR EVERYONE.
IF CANDIDATES ARE ONLY
ACCOUNTABLE TO A SMALL NUMBER OF
PARTISAN EXECUTIVES IN NEW YORK
AND SAN FRANCISCO, THEY ARE
UNLIKELY TO CARE WHEN YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD POLICE STATION IS
ON FIRE, FOR EXAMPLE.
THEY PROBABLY WON’T BE TOO UPSET
WHEN PACKS OF MENTALLY ILL
HOMELESS TAKE OVER YOUR SCREEN
OR WHEN YOUR NEPHEW OVERDOSES ON
FENTANYL.
THEY HAVE NO INCENTIVE TO
IMPROVE YOUR LIFE, IN OTHER
WORDS.
INSTEAD THEY CAN JUST LECTURE
YOU ABOUT YOUR MORAL FAILINGS,
AND THEY ARE.
THAT’S THE SYSTEM WE HAVE NOW
CARRIED KAMALA HARRIS EMBODIES
IT.
IT’S ALL PRETTY SAD AND
UNNERVING WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
IT.
WHAT IF YOU HAD AN ELECTION AND
NO ONE CARED WHAT VOTERS
THOUGHT?
WE ARE ABOUT TO FIND OUT, BUT
BEFORE YOU GET TOO DEPRESSED
TAKE THIS MOMENT TO ENJOY THE
BREATHTAKING ABSURDITY OF IT
ALL.
THE MOST OBLIVIOUS POLITICIAN IN
AMERICA HAS JOINED FORCES WITH
THE MOST CALCULATING POLITICIAN
IN AMERICA.
HILARITY ENSUES.
NEITHER ONE BELIEVES ANYTHING,
BUT ONLY ONE OF THEM KNOWS WHAT
DAY IT IS.
WHEN BIDEN CALLED HARRIS
YESTERDAY, FOR EXAMPLE, THERE
WAS A SCRIPT VISIBLE ON HIS
DESK, SO THE DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE
FOR PRESIDENT IS UNABLE TO SPEAK
TO HIS RUNNING MATE WITHOUT
ASSISTANCE.
HERE’S HOW IT WENT.
>> HI, SORRY TO KEEP YOU.
>> THAT’S ALL RIGHT.
ARE YOU READY TO GO TO WORK?
>> OH, MY GOD.
I AM SO READY TO GO TO WORK.
>> FIRST OF ALL, IS THE ANSWER
YES?
>> THE ANSWER IS ABSOLUTELY YES,
JOE, AND I’M READY TO WORK, I AM
READY TO DO THIS WITH YOU, FOR
YOU.
I JUST -- I’M JUST DEEPLY
HONORED AND I’M VERY EXCITED.
>> Tucker: THAT’S JUST TOO
GREAT, WE ARE KEEPING THAT ON A
LOOP IN THE TAPE DEPARTMENT.
I’M SORRY TO KEEP YOU,
KAMALA HARRIS SAYS.
NOT SINCE ELIZABETH WARREN
PRETENDED TO DRINK A BEER WITH
HER HUSBAND HAS AN EXCHANGE THAT
FAKE BEEN CAPTURED ON VIDEO.
THERE WERE A MEXICAN SOAP OPERAS
MORE AUTHENTIC THAN WHAT YOU
JUST SAW.
AND IF YOU STILL HAVE TO WONDER
HOW MANY TIMES DID THEY HAVE TO
RESHOOT THAT SCENE BEFORE
JOE BIDEN GOT HIS LINES RIGHT,
LET’S TRY AGAIN,
MR. VICE PRESIDENT, WARM,
PERSONAL CONVERSATION, TAKE 11.
IT’S GOING TO BE A DEEPLY
AMUSING THREE MONTHS.
DO YOUR BEST TO ENJOY IT.
BUT AS YOU DO ENJOY IT, PAY
ATTENTION ALSO TO WHAT HARRIS
SAYS SHE BELIEVES.
SHE WILL TRY TO SAY NOT MUCH
ABOUT WHAT SHE BELIEVES, PUBLIC
POLICY IS THE LAST THING THE
BIDEN CAMPAIGN WANTS TO TALK
ABOUT.
THE PLAN IS TO SKATE BY ON
HARRIS’ HISTORIC STATUS COMBINED
WITH THE RELENTLESS ATTACKS ON
THE INCUMBENT.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" FOR ONE IS
ON BOARD.
THE TIMES DOESN’T THINK YOU
SHOULD WORRY ABOUT WHAT HARRIS
PLANS TO DO TO YOUR COUNTRY IF
SHE IS ELECTED.
MOMENTS AFTER HARRIS JOINED THE
BIDEN CAMPAIGN, THE PAPER
DECLARED HER A "PRAGMATIC
MODERATE."
SO WHY DID THEY FEEL THE NEED TO
SUM HER UP THAT WAY?
WHILE OBVIOUSLY TO SEND A VERY
CLEAR SIGNAL TO EVERYONE ELSE IN
THE BUSINESS.
AT THIS LATE STAGE IN AMERICAN
JOURNALISM, "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
EXISTS PRIMARILY AS AN
ASSIGNMENT EDITOR FOR PRODUCERS
AT CNN.
IF THE TIMES DECLARES IT, THE
26-YEAR-OLD BASS OR GRADS WHO
DECIDE WHAT’S ON CABLE
TELEVISION FAITHFULLY REPEAT IT.
SO EXPECT TO HEAR QUITE A BIT
ABOUT HARRIS’ PRAGMATIC
MODERATIONS IN COMING WEEKS.
YOU PROBABLY ALREADY ARE.
THE QUESTION IS WE ARE
CONSIDERING, IS KAMALA HARRIS
ACTUALLY A MODERATE?
LET’S SEE.
HERE SHE IS LESTER CALLING FOR
CONGRESS TO CHANGE THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES SO THAT
16-YEAR-OLDS CAN VOTE.
AS YOU WATCH IT, FOR THE SAKE OF
ARGUMENT, PRETEND THAT HARRIS
MEANS WHAT SHE SAID AND THEN ASK
YOURSELF, "WHAT KIND OF PERSON
CAN MAKE AN ARGUMENT LIKE THAT,
IN PUBLIC, WITHOUT BLUSHING"?
ONLY SOMEONE WHO HAD NEVER
ACTUALLY MET A 16-YEAR-OLD.
>> DO BELIEVE THAT AMERICANS
SHOULD HAVE THE RIGHT TO VOTE AT
AGE 16?
>> I’M REALLY INTERESTED IN
HAVING THAT CONVERSATION.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU THAT.
I THINK THAT THERE IS NO
QUESTION THAT IF WE ARE LOOKING
AT WHAT IS GOING ON IN OUR
COUNTRY, WE ARE PUTTING MORE
RESPONSE ABILITIES ON PEOPLE AT
A YOUNGER AGE AND THE LARGER
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT WE CAN
INVOLVED IN THE ELECTORAL
PROCESS, I THINK THE MORE ROBUST
IT WOULD BE.
>> Tucker: THERE IS NO
QUESTION, HARRIS SAYS, THAT
TURNING THE GOVERNMENT OVER
210TH GRADERS WOULD MAKE THE
COUNTRY MORE ROBUST.
FOR SURE.
NO MORE SCHOOL, FREE DAB PENS
FOR EVERYONE.
ENDLESS POSSIBILITIES FOR MORE
ROBUSTNESS.
DOES HARRIS REALLY BELIEVE THAT?
A FEW YEARS AGO SHE HAD THIS
ASSESSMENT OF YOUNG PEOPLE.
WATCH.
>> WE MOLD AND SHAPE AND DIRECT
SOMEONE TO BECOME A PRODUCTIVE
ADULT.
WHAT’S THE OTHER THING WE KNOW
ABOUT THIS POPULATION, AND IT’S
A SPECIFIC PHASE OF LIFE,
REMEMBER, AGES MORE THAN A
CHRONOLOGICAL FACT.
WHAT ELSE DO WE KNOW ABOUT THIS
POPULATION, 18 THROUGH 24?
THEY ARE STUPID.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
SHE’S RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
SO PUT TOGETHER HER TWO
STATEMENTS ON THE SUBJECT.
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE STUPID, AND
THAT’S WHY WE NEED MORE OF THEM
TO VOTE.
AND IT MAKES SENSE, IN FACT,
WHEN THE ENTIRE ELECTORATE IS AS
PASSIVE AS JOE BIDEN HAS BECOME,
YOU CAN PRETTY MUCH DO WHAT YOU
WANT.
YOU CAN WIELD TOTAL CONTROL.
THAT’S WHAT HARRIS IS ARGUING.
SAY WHAT YOU WILL ABOUT THAT
POSITION, BUT IT IS NOT IN ANY
SENSE MODERATE.
IT’S RADICAL.
AND MANY OF HARRIS’ VIEWS ARE
WHETHER YOU LIKE IT OR NOT.
CONSIDER THIS TAPE IN WHICH SHE
CLAIMS ALL THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SHOULD RESPOND TO THE
CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC.
AGAIN, WHATEVER YOU THINK OF
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION, IT’S LIKE
YOU NEVER IMAGINED AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION WOULD BE APPLIED TO
LIFE-SAVING MEDICAL TREATMENT,
BUT KAMALA HARRIS THINKS IT
SHOULD BE.
>> THE DISPARITIES THAT HAVE
LONG EXISTED BASED ON RACE ARE
NOW HIGHLIGHTED, SO ONE OF THE
THINGS I’M CALLING FOR AROUND
THIS PANDEMIC IS THAT WE MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT WHERE THE
RESOURCES SHOULD GO BASED ON
THAT ISSUE.
>> Tucker: SO WE MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT WHERE THE
RESOURCES SHOULD GO TO KEEP
PEOPLE FROM DYING ON THE BASIS
OF SKIN COLOR.
SO ONLY PEOPLE OF A CERTAIN
COLOR GET THE VACCINE, FOR
EXAMPLE.
THAT’S WHAT SHE’S ARGUING.
THIS IS A LOT OF THINGS.
IT’S IMMORAL.
IT’S UNCONSTITUTIONAL,
OBVIOUSLY.
BUT ABOVE ALL IT IS DEFINITELY
NOT MODERATE.
NOR IS THIS, BY THE WAY.
HERE’S HARRIS AND THE SENATE
FROM TWO YEARS AGO TELLING THE
ACTING DIRECTOR OF ICE THAT
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
ARE A DOMESTIC TERROR GROUP.
>> THE CLAN WAS WHAT WE WOULD
CALL TODAY AT DOMESTIC TERRORIST
GROUP.
>> WHY?
WHY WOULD WE CALL THEM DOMESTIC
TERRORIST GROUP?
>> BECAUSE THEY TRIED TO USE
FEAR AND FORCE TO CHANGE
POLITICAL ENVIRONMENT.
>> AND WHAT WAS THE MOTIVATION
FOR THE USE OF FEAR AND FORCE?
>> IS BASED ON RACE AND
ETHNICITY.
>> RIGHT.
ARE YOU AWARE OF THE PERCEPTION
OF MANY ABOUT HOW THE POWER AND
THE DISCRETION AT ICE IS BEING
USED TO ENFORCE THE LAWS?
AND DO YOU SEE ANY PARALLELS?
>> Tucker: ARE YOU AWARE OF
THE PERCEPTION?
AND DO YOU SEE ANY PARALLELS
BETWEEN FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS IN THE KKK?
HARRIS WANTED TO KNOW.
BUT NOT REALLY.
THE ANSWER OF COURSE WASN’T
EMBEDDED IN THE QUESTION.
EVER NOTICE YOU ACT A LOT LIKE
HITLER?
SHE WASN’T REALLY ASKING
ANYTHING.
SHE WAS ATTACKING AND DOING IT
IN THE SLEAZIEST MOST
PASSIVE-AGGRESSIVE POSSIBLE WAY.
BUT DON’T FIGHT BACK, DON’T EVEN
THINK ABOUT IT, BECAUSE THE ONLY
PEOPLE WHO CRITICIZE
KAMALA HARRIS ARE MORALLY BAD
PEOPLE.
SHE’S BEEN MAKING THAT VERY
CLEAR FOR YEARS.
SHE’S EVEN BEEN WILLING TO
ATTACK HER FELLOW DEMOCRATS.
LAST FALL AS HER PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN BEGAN TO COLLAPSE FROM
LACK OF POPULAR SUPPORT FROM
VOTERS, HARRIS SUGGESTED THE
REAL PROBLEM WAS THAT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, HER PARTY, HAD
TOO MANY RACIST IN IT.
>> WHAT I DESCRIBED IN WHAT I
BELIEVE TO BE THE ELEPHANT IN
THE ROOM ABOUT MY CAMPAIGN.
>> WHAT IS THAT?
>> ELECTABILITY.
ELECTABILITY.
ESSENTIALLY, IS AMERICA READY
FOR A WOMAN AND A WOMAN OF COLOR
TO BE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES?
>> AMERICA WAS READY FOR A BLACK
MAN TO BE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> AND THIS CONVERSATION
HAPPENED FOR HIM.
THERE IS A LACK OF ABILITY, OR A
DIFFICULTY IN IMAGINING THAT
SOMEONE WILL WE HAVE NEVER SEEN
CAN DO A JOB THAT HAS BEEN DONE,
YOU KNOW, 45 TIMES BY SOMEONE
WHO IS NOT THAT PERSON.
>> Tucker: IS AMERICA READY?
AGAIN, IT’S ALL PRETTY AMUSING,
AND YES, TO ANSWER HER QUESTION,
AMERICA IS INDEED READY FOR A
BLACK PRESIDENT.
WE ELECTED ONE TWICE.
BUT IS AMERICA READY FOR A
SHALLOW, HECTORING RICH LADY
WHOSE ONLY REAL FANS WORK AT
HEDGE FUNDS AND MSNBC?
THAT’S THE REAL QUESTION HERE,
BUT DON’T EXPECT ANYONE IN
AUTHORITY TO ASK IT.
INSTEAD, EXPECT MORE LYING, MORE
PROPAGANDA.
WE ARE SEEING IT EVERYWHERE JUST
IN THE LAST 24 HOURS.
IN NOVEMBER, FOR EXAMPLE,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" DESCRIBED
KAMALA HARRIS AS "AN UNEVEN
CAMPAIGNER WHO CHANGES HER
MESSAGE AND TACTICS TO LITTLE
EFFECT AND HAS A STAFF TORN INTO
FACTIONS."
BUT THAT’S NO LONGER TRUE.
YOU KNOW WHY?
BECAUSE IT’S ELECTION SEASON.
IT’S TIME TO TAKE OUT THE ORANGE
MENACE!
SO "THE NEW YORK TIMES" HAS
REVISED ITS VIEW.
HARRIS IS NOW "A POLITICAL
WARRIOR SHAPED BY LIFE IN TWO
WORLDS" AND NEEDLESS TO SAY
SHE’S A PRAGMATIC MODERATE.
THE MEDIA VEHEMENTLY AGREE WITH
THIS.
IN FACT THEY WERE SO EXCITED
ABOUT KAMALA HARRIS GETTING A
RAISE THAT FOR A MOMENT FACED
FORGOT TO SCREAM AT THEIR MAKEUP
ARTISTS.
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS COMING AND
IT WAS INCREDIBLY EXCITING NEWS
WHEN IT CAME.
>> JUST A REMARKABLE MOMENT TO
CARE ABOUT WOMEN’S ISSUES.
SHE CARES ABOUT EQUALITY DEEP
WITHIN HERSELF AND SHE DOES
HAVE, KIND OF A CHARISMA, I
DON’T WANT TO USE CELEBRITY, BUT
IN POLITICAL TERMS, SHE DOES.
>> AS THEY HAD POINTED OUT
THERE, A REMARKABLE RISE AND AS
YOU POINTED OUT, SHE IS A
FIGHTER.
>> SHE’S SMART, SHE’S QUICK ON
HER FEET, SHE’S ARTICULATE.
>> ONE OF THE PLUSES FOR
KAMALA HARRIS CANDIDACY IS HER
PERSONAL MAGNETISM.
>> THIS IS A PHENOMENAL PICK
TONIGHT.
>> PEOPLE WANTED TO BE AROUND
HER.
THERE WAS A CHARISMA, A
FASCINATION, FOR LACK OF A
BETTER WORD, A BIT OF CELEBRITY
SURROUNDED KAMALA HARRIS.
>> I IMMEDIATELY UNDERSTOOD WHY
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA SAW HER AS
THE FEMALE OBAMA.
>> Tucker: SHE’S REMARKABLE.
REALLY THE QUESTION IS IF SHE
GIVES A CAMPAIGN SPEECH OR MY
POSITION OF ELEVATION, IS IT A
SERMON ON THE MOUND?
NEWS AT 11.
THE ANCHORS ON CNN OF COURSE
WERE ESPECIALLY SUPPORTIVE.
IN FACT, KAMALA HARRIS IS THE
ONLY POLITICIAN, THEIR BOSS, THE
TINY BUT SECRETIVE JEFF ZUCKER,
HAS EVERY PUBLICLY ENDORSED.
WHEN SHE RAN FOR
ATTORNEY GENERAL, HE SAID THIS,
"SHE’S NOT JUST IMPORTANT FOR
THE CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO, THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA, BUT FOR THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY."
SO ACCORDING TO JEFF ZUCKER,
KAMALA HARRIS IS THAT IMPORTANT.
EXISTENTIALLY IMPORTANT,
SPIRITUALLY IMPORTANT.
PROBABLY TOO IMPORTANT TO COVER
AS YOU WOULD A MERE POLITICIAN